Mon père était bizarre
et à un moment, il m'a dit :
“Ta mère, tu peux pas aller la voir.”
Et il m'a dit qu'elle s'était fait taper
et sur le coup, j'ai pas compris.
Salut, c'est Juliette
et la fille que vous venez de voir,
c'est Océane.
Aujourd'hui, je voulais
vous raconter son histoire
et celle de tant d'autres enfants
qui témoignent au quotidien
de violences conjugales dans leur famille.
En fait, quand on parle de violences
conjugales, j'ai l'impression qu'on oublie
souvent les enfants, alors qu'en France,
ils seraient environ 150000
à vivre dans des foyers
où des violences ont été signalées.
Ah, les enfants,
ils comprennent.
On comprend très bien,
on n'est pas stupides,
on n'a pas la distance,
on n'a pas le côté...
la vision adulte de la chose
et donc je pense que c'est pour ça
qu'on voit encore plus.
C'est qu'on n'a pas le côté : “Oui, il faut
rester ensemble, parce qu'il y a des...
Économiquement, par rapport
aux vues que les gens auront sur nous.”
Non, nous, on voit juste que ça ne va pas.
Et puis c'est tout.
Il y a quelques semaines,
une de nos journalistes,
Gabrielle, a sorti un documentaire
sur notre plateforme BrutX,
qui racontait l'histoire de Lydie,
une femme qui a survécu à des années
de violences conjugales.
La veille de mon mariage,
je reçois des coups,
quand je te dis des coups,
sur tout mon corps, c’est-à-dire
que quand je me déshabille,
je suis bleue.
J’étais devenue sa propriété,
il m’a dit “maintenant, tu parle plus,
tu te tais, tu écoutes”.
Sur notre compte TikTok,
on a mis plusieurs extraits
de ce documentaire,
dont un de sa fille, Océane,
qui vous a fait beaucoup réagir.
Il y a eu beaucoup de questions
sur la situation d'Océane
et aussi beaucoup de témoignages.
Du coup, j'ai décidé
de relancer une messagerie
pour que les gens puissent
me raconter un peu plus.
Salut Brut,
je t'appelle parce que là, il faut que je crie,
il faut que je parle, il faut que je dise, là, c'est grave.
"Arrête papa, fais pas ça."
Vraiment, il avait l'intention de la tuer.
Pour comprendre les angoisses quotidiennes
que peuvent vivre les enfants en situation
de violence conjugale dans leur famille,
on a choisi de donner complètement
la parole à Océane
pour qu'elle puisse vous raconter
son histoire en détails.
Je me souviens plus vraiment quand ma mère et mon ex-beau-père se sont rencontrés,
j'étais beaucoup, beaucoup plus jeune
et je faisais pas vraiment attention.
Elle m’a juste dit un jour que  :
“Bah, j'ai rencontré quelqu'un.”
Et ça devait vraiment être sérieux
pour qu'elle me le présente.
Ah, la première fois que je l'ai vu,
le premier truc que je me suis dit,
c'est qu'il était grand, mais qu'il avait l'air gentil et que ma mère souriait beaucoup.
Mon premier souvenir,
de quand je l'ai vu la première fois,
c'est au parc, juste à côté de chez maman,
il y avait un grand parc,
et on s'était tous les trois réunis là
et je me souviens qu’il m'avait portée
sur ses épaules, qu'on avait rigolé
et qu'il était super gentil.
Le moment où j'ai commencé à avoir
plus de doutes par rapport à lui,
c'est bizarre mais c'est flou en soi,
c’est que j’ai pas de moment précis.
C'est juste que quand j'y repense,
j'ai pas la notion du temps.
C'est juste qu’à un moment,
je me dis... quand je les entends parler
ou surtout quand je l'entends, lui, parler,
que je me dis : c'est bizarre.
Normalement, ça ne se passe pas comme ça...
Parce que moi, j’ai pas grandi
dans cette ambiance-là,
moi, j’avais mes deux parents qui s’aimaient, même s’ils n’étaient plus ensemble.
On rigolait, ça s’amusait,
il y avait pas de violence.
Donc, avec mon ex-beau-père,
c’étaient les disputes, les insultes,
tentatives de contrôle et quand
ça ne marche pas, tu insultes encore et encore,
et les cris, beaucoup, beaucoup de cris.
La première fois que je me suis dit ça,
que ma mère était une femme battue,
ça a dû prendre du temps parce qu'il n'y avait pas cette relation de : où elle était fragile,
muette, qu'elle se laissait faire...
Mais je me souviens
que j'étais chez ma grand-mère,
pendant une semaine, je pense,
pendant les vacances,
et elle m'avait envoyé un SMS
qui disait : “Ne rentre pas.”
Sur le coup, je n'ai pas compris,
mais mon père était bizarre et je me souviens qu'il est rentré chez ma grand-mère,
il s'est assis à côté de moi, on a parlé
et à un moment, il m'a dit :
“Ta mère, tu peux pas aller la voir.”
Au début, j'ai pas compris...
Et il m'a dit qu'elle s'était fait taper
et sur le coup, j'ai pas compris.
J'ai réussi à rentrer à la maison au bout de quelques jours, même pas, un ou deux jours,
et elle était défigurée.
Elle avait l'œil qui se fermait,
elle avait la mâchoire démise
et elle avait des bleus.
Je l'ai haï quand je l'ai vu la fois d'après,
parce que je pensais qu'on le verrait plus,
mais en même temps, je suis pas naïve,
donc, je me doutais qu'on allait le revoir.
Mais ma mère, elle est forte,
donc elle passe au-dessus des choses.
Si elle a... si elle arrive à pardonner,
elle oublie et elle passe.
Mais moi, j'arrive pas.
Je faisais juste attention aux bruits, en fait,
aux types de bruits qui se passaient.
Le moindre... le moindre coup
ou bruit, je l’entendais
et j'arrêtais de bouger pour voir
s’il allait se passer quelque chose après,
et des fois, j'avais mon téléphone qui était allumé avec le numéro des urgences au cas où.
C'est devenu plus compliqué
quand mon petit frère et ma petite sœur,
ils ont commencé à grandir,
parce que je ne voulais pas
qu'ils soient...
Je voulais pas qu’ils soient obnubilés par ça.
Moi, quand j'ai grandi, j’avais pas ça.
C'était pas tout rose, tout beau,
mais il n'y avait pas de violence.
Donc, pour eux, je ne voulais pas qu'il y en ait
et puis, je savais que ça allait leur faire peur.
Donc, quand ça se mettait à crier
ou à taper contre les murs,
je les prenais avec moi, j'allais dans leur chambre et je me mettais à chanter et danser.
Pour que le bruit contrebalance.
Alors, il y a une fois, c'était pendant la nuit,
j'avais cours le lendemain,
donc j'étais énervée, saoulée, fatiguée,
et donc je pense que ma mère, elle était...
oui, ma mère était enceinte à ce moment-là.
Donc, tout ça a fait que je me suis énervée, j'avais un verre d'eau, je suis allée dans le salon
et je lui ai jeté à la tête.
Sauf que c'est pas passé,
qu’il s'est levé... Sachant qu'il fait quoi ?
1 mètre 90. Et qu'il a commencé
à avancer vite vers moi.
Et je me souviens que ma mère m'a littéralement poussée dans ma chambre,
elle a fermé la porte
et elle s'est mise devant la porte.
Donc, je voyais plus ce qui se passait, mais j'entendais que ça tapait contre la porte, fort,
et les hurlements,
jusqu'au moment où il est parti.
Mais j'ai pas osé sortir de ma chambre.
Quand il y avait de très grosses disputes,
il n'était pas là pendant un jour, peut-être deux,
et après, il revenait, il faisait
comme si tout allait bien.
Il faisait des cadeaux, il était super gentil.
Dédoublement de la personnalité complet.
Et ma mère passait outre,
parce que le pardon, c'est important.
La maman d'Océane a eu trois enfants
avec son agresseur
et c'est pour les protéger, eux,
qu’Océane s’est préparée au pire.
J'ai souvent eu peur de ne pas revoir ma mère, ouais, j'ai même fait un plan dans ma tête
de comment je ferais si elle était plus là,
par rapport à eux, par rapport
à comment ça s’organiserait.
Qu'est-ce que je ferais ? Où j’irais ?
C'est que si jamais elle venait à mourir,
il faudrait que j’ai la garde
exclusive des enfants.
Donc, avec maman, on en a parlé, elle m'a dit qu’i faudrait que j'aille voir son avocate.
J'avais prévu de faire des cours à distance, parce qu'on peut le faire à la fac,
et de m'éloigner de Paris, d'aller vers la banlieue
pour pouvoir leur prendre une maison un peu plus grande pour pas qu'ils soient malheureux
en plus de la perte de la mère.
Honnêtement, quand ils se remettaient ensemble, quand ils se séparaient,
quand ils se remettaient ensemble...
je faisais même plus de commentaires,
ça m’a vidée, ça m’a fatiguée,
je faisais plus attention.
C'est triste à dire, c'est horrible, mais on est...
on est... on est fatigué de faire des efforts,
à essayer, donc on la laisse
et je sais que la dernière fois,
quand ils se sont réellement séparés,
quand elle me l’a dit, je l'ai pas crue.
Je lui disais “oui, oui, oui”, et je pense
qu'elle savait que je la croyais pas
et ça a dû lui faire mal,
parce que j'avais aucune...
J'étais persuadée
qu'elle arriverait jamais à s'en détacher.
Mais elle a réussi.
Finalement, après cinq longues années
de violences, avec des plaintes déposées
et puis retirées,
Lydie, la maman d'Océane,
a réussi à s'en sortir.
L'ancien beau-père d'Océane a été condamné
à six mois de prison avec sursis.
Alors, aujourd’hui, ma mère, elle a
une ordonnance restrictive par rapport à lui.
Mais c’est un bout de papier, littéralement.
Pour moi, c’est une vaste blague.
Déjà, faut la renouveler constamment,
alors que je vois même pas
l’intérêt de la renouveler.
Donc, ouais, on a une épée de Damoclès
au-dessus de la tête.
Il faut savoir que bien souvent,
les frais engagés en justice
ne sont pas remboursés
et qu'il y a très peu
de prise en charge psychologique
pour les victimes directes ou indirectes.
Aujourd'hui, Océane
et sa maman, Lydie, vont bien,
mais il y a encore beaucoup de familles
qui vivent dans le traumatisme
des violences conjugales.
Si vous ou un de vos proches
êtes victime de violences conjugales,
vous pouvez appeler le 39 19.
C'est un numéro accessible 24 heures sur 24.
Si vous avez trouvé
ce reportage intéressant,
vous pouvez vous abonner à notre chaîne Brut
pour voir d'autres contenus similaires
et n'hésitez pas
à m’envoyer un message sur Instagram,
si vous avez des idées
d'autres sujets qui vous touchent.